Starting from the pseudo code from the hint video, and get
set to the credit card number. Sum is set to 0. Count
is also set to 0, and that's an int. And now
for the tricky part, for each digit in n starting from the
right. So I need to use the parts of this while
loop that correspond to that. So I'll keep while n is greater
than 0 and n equals n over 10. And I need
to actually get the digit so that I can add it. But
I don't just want to add the digit to the
sum. I only want to do that if count is
odd and I need to increment count. So count
plus, plus. And if count is odd then add digit
to the sum. But count is odd is not quite Java yet. If count mod 2 is 1
then count is odd. And instead of printing the
sum, I'll return it. And if I run the tester,
so far so good. I don't see any evidence that I made mistakes.